As Governor, DeSantis
moves closer to an expected
presidential bid.
CNN's case
file has uncovered
some disturbing comments
by a new DeSantis appointee,
Andrew Kozinski
who is the senior
editor of K File,
is joining us now on this.
Andrew, tell us what you found here.
Yeah, that's right.
A history of anti-gay comments
from Ron Perry.
He was one of those appointed by Ron
DeSantis to the new board
governing the special tax district
that governs Disney.
Now, people
remember when this group, Disney,
they spoke out against the don't say
gay bill.
They were effectively punished
by DeSantis by replacing the old board
those who had ties to Disney
with this new board.
Now, Perry, he is an Orlando based
former pastor.
He runs a group called The Gathering
The Gathering had Zoom sessions,
which he later posted on YouTube.
And what we found was
in those Zoom sessions,
he made a variety of anti-gay comments
There is even this one where he bizarrely
suggests
that water could be turning people gay
because of hormones in it.
Let's take a listen to that one.
So
why are there homosexuals today?
There are any number of reasons
he has ever given.
Some would say
the increase
in estrogen in our society is,
you know, there's estrogen in the water
from the
from birth control pills.
They can't get it out.
But the big part
I would suggest to you, based
upon what it's saying here,
is the removal of constraint.
Well, you remove the constraints
and then evil occurs
Now, we should first off point out
that there is no evidence
for either of those claims made by him.
We did reach out to
DeSantis, his administration.
We did reach out to Perry.
We didn't hear back from either of them.
You can read those comments
and others from Perry, an article
we just posted on CNN dot com.
All right.
We'll be looking for that.
Andrew Kosinski, thank you so much.
I want to bring back Kristen Holmes
along with our CNN
national politics reporter. Evan Weekend.
Ever first,
I mean, your reaction
to what Andrew found in this case
file reporting
and do you think this is going to hurt
Governor DeSantis?
You know, Brianna,
I don't anticipate
that there is going to be
any significant
political consequences for the governor.
What we have seen in Florida
is there is a limit to Democratic outrage
there is a limit. Yes.
We're going to hear Democrats
shake their head
at this, angry about this,
but there is a limit to what they can do.
Also, in my conversations
with conservatives
who hold marginalized identities
over the years,
they have suggested that ignorance
like this rank ignorance like this
is sort of the cost of doing business
They agree with Governor DeSantis
on a whole number of policies, taxes,
limited government.
So is do they
are they going to feel like
this is great, that this man has referred
to gay folks as deviant,
shameful, unhealthy,
suggesting that you become gay
by drinking tap water?
Probably not.
But I don't see a groundswell
of gay
conservatives in Florida
trying to challenge Governor DeSantis
when they have supported him
on so many issues in the recent past.
And you know, Christian DeSantis
skipping CPAC there.
So he gets to avoid one of those
like Nikki Haley moments
that you highlighted
where she's getting kind of heckled
by the pro.
Trump said
he can't avoid the larger
issue, though, of Trump
and how he navigates
the hold that Trump
clearly has still on part of the GOP
primary.
Well, that's right, Brianna.
And that's been the big question
is how he's going to walk this fine line.
The thing to remember
is that DeSantis in 2018
not only ran
with the endorsement
that he sought from Donald Trump,
he also ran on a MAGA platform.
We all remember that
ad for Governor in 2018
in which he is reading
the art of the deal to his child.
He's teaching another child
how to build the wall
and referencing Trump
in that Florida ad nonstop.
So he clearly was trying to appeal
to the base.
And I will tell you
that there are a number of people
that I spoke to here
who say that
they actually liked DeSantis a lot.
Even the people who say they want Trump
to be president in 20, 24.
So they like to say
is they just don't believe it's his turn.
The question is whether or not
he can continue
to stave off these insults
from former President Donald Trump.
I mean, for the last several weeks,
we have seen Trump
just go after
DeSantis audio through social
as well as
in interviews, calling him
disloyal, hitting his COVID policies.
And the list goes on
and on, hitting him
over Social Security and Medicare.
Now, the question again,
whether or not to say
this can't continue to just blow this off
as noise.
He's not going to hit other Republicans
or if at some point
he actually decides to take on former
President Trump.
And then what does that look like
for this Republican base?
Do people split?
Do they go towards Donald Trump?
This is a group
that has been very loyal to him.
But again,
there are people there
who like Ron DeSantis.
So he has a very fine line here
that he has to navigate
all of these candidates.
Do and we'll be watching them.
Eva and Kristen, thank you to
both of you.